all right
let's talk about on the best business
show
potentially
the best entertainer of all time
potentially the goat
potentially on goat mountain mr
billionaire kanye west
he now has not dropped his album
he has also held three listening parties
in atlanta and chicago
and they estimate
that he has made over 12 million dollars
before he has even dropped the actual
album absolutely
nuts when you think about how much cash
kanye west is printing right now
he last night held the third listening
party in chicago at soldier field
that listening party brought i believe a
sellout audience he sold merch
and he let himself on fire
he built his old childhood home on the
field it was nuts 12 million dollars
they say kanye west has already made
for this album release but he hasn't
even released the album yet
kanye west what do we think in terms of
uh what he's pulled off here we've got
joe's tweet that we can pull up in terms
of uh what he said about kanye
um let's see if we can pull
it up in a minute
kanye west made everyone wait 30 plus
days for the album he held three
listening parties in atlanta and chicago
he rebuilt his childhood home in the
stadium he lit himself on fire he got
married again and sold over 12 million
dollars in tickets merch etc and some of
you don't think he's a genius is he is
he goat status now yeah he's got a
status
i mean who who could do this well i i
honestly think uh like it's obviously
been pre-planned kind of what his uh
what his deal is and i think what he's
really doing is he's just recreating the
process for an album drop right no one's
ever done it like this where they're
actually holding listening parties
multiple of them across different cities
and selling out uh merch and doing tours
and stuff like that before they actually
release the album some people think that
uh he's just kind of crazy and he's just
doing it as he goes some people think
that it's a master calculated plan i
assume it's probably somewhere in
between but what we're seeing is like
he's totally flipped the industry on its
head from an entertainment standpoint
right like this is just not the way
music was traditionally done
traditionally you release the songs you
go on tour afterwards and it's all kind
of calculated on on how you're gonna
make your money from ticketing to
merchandising et cetera and he's gone
and he's just flipped it completely and
he said i'm gonna do it a different way
i'm gonna do it a multiple different
story uh multiple different cities and
i'm gonna tell a story while i do it and
i think it's genius i think uh what
we've seen is he's been able to command
the attention of people for over all
months now right uh from not even
dropping the album but doing it from
merch uh listening concerts everything
the album still hasn't dropped i think
people are getting a little uh anxious
for that and you can only do this for so
long but if it drops in the next week or
whatever it is then this is all a good
plan because what he's done is he's just
gotten free marketing and he's drummed
up interest and not even free he's made
money while doing it so i think it's
smart uh and i think we're gonna see
other artists try to replicate this in
some capacity
is he gonna drop the album like what if
he never drops the album
he'll drop an album but i think the
concern is that one it's not done yet
right like so i think some people i
don't know if it's done right i think uh
there's probably more people that are
more in tune with kind of the music and
stuff like that that probably have a
better idea but there's definitely
whispers that it's not done yet uh or
yeah he won't drop it or uh he's
finishing some things or maybe he even
has it ready i know that he's selling
these devices which are like 200 dollars
that have the songs pre-recorded on them
which is genius again because he's just
gonna make more money doing that he's
selling songs for 200. yeah and he just
happens to have put them onto the device
that probably costs essentially
five dollars yeah the bluetooth speaker
and so he's essentially selling
unreleased music for 200 per person and
it's genius because you can't take the
bluetooth
uh device and upload it or leak it or do
anything it's stuck in a device and so
literally if you want the whole album
what do you have to do spend a thousand
dollars yeah it's a social experiment
it's just like if you and your friends
want to go listen to it you're all gonna
go buy the thing you're gonna
he i mean he's commanded the internet
now for a month right everyone on
twitter has been talking about uh his
listening parties his shows the
merchandise and all the stuff i actually
saw a good point about it earlier too
they were talking about how he's changed
the merchandise uh business for artists
when you traditionally think about it
you would go to a concert and t-shirts
were ten dollars five dollars scalpers
for selling them whatever right they
were very uh kind of cheap and they were
used as mementos for you to be able to
tell people that you went to a show you
attended a concert you were there and
now what he's done is he's taken that
fashion business that he created and
he's he's moved it within kind of his uh
ecosystem of entertainment and music and
now he's selling
the merch line yesterday uh i don't know
if we have a picture of it eventually
but it was it was a massive there was
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people waiting there to buy 100 t-shirts
200 sweatshirts all the stuff that's
extremely expensive and what he's done
now is create this ecosystem where his
merch plays off his music and his music
plays off his merch and then he's able
to do live events and concerts still
where artists would traditionally make
the most money there's photos from uh
the second listening uh event and then
also from last night that we're gonna
pull up here and when you see these some
of these photos feels like this is like
iconic stuff right that literally 20
years from now we'll be like hey man do
you remember when kanye lit himself on
fire yeah right and people like what and
but yeah dude look like here's a photo
uh we've got the here's the one of him
actually lighting himself on fire that
is kanye west when i tweeted this
earlier and i said some people think
he's still not a genius they were saying
they said lighting yourself on fire not
to not sounds real genius
[Laughter]
i was like yeah i guess yeah yeah yeah
but he sold out the stadiums made 12
million dollars and he literally has the
entire world in the palm of his hands
waiting for him to drop the album he's a
creative genius yeah he's definitely a
creative genius uh the second photo that
we have is of the actual uh home that he
built uh in terms of he rebuilt his
childhood home
on soldier field and he's got smoke
coming out everywhere uh and um steven
gallanis uh cameo ceo shout out to cameo
uh was there last night and he was
tweeting and he's posting on instagram
and stuff and he's like dude we wait for
an hour 45 minutes kanye's not here i
thought he i think he said like it was
like 1 30 in the morning and he wasn't
there or something right crazy yeah i
don't think it was that late but it was
pretty i mean that'd be wild yeah
right there we should have gone we
should have went we should have
definitely gone all right so if we have
to judge kanye on two things one is
kanye a creative genius
i john just said yeah all right
man kanye creative genius two is kanye a
genius businessman i uh yeah is john is
kanye the goat musician he almost says
john the goat musician but what that guy
is kanye the goat musician
i wouldn't say no no no
john
oh john thinks that connie is the ghost
well i think that's where people get uh
confused when you talk about him being a
genius right they take it as in he's the
best artist ever and all this stuff i
don't think it's that i think it's the
combination of him being a really good
artist but also being one of the best
business focused artists from that
perspective that we've ever seen right
so he owns 100
of yeezy right which is a billion dollar
company uh he claims that he was what
was the story he was 53 million dollars
in debt and he has mark zuckerberg uh
for what do you want he wanted a billion
dollars give me a billion dollars i need
money for my ideas
because i want you to invest in my ideas
mark zuckerberg is like no dude he's
probably like what ideas well guess what
he should have guess what kanye's worth
6.6 billion dollars now yeah but i mean
that's the thing right like he has done
a better job than anyone of developing
his talent from a business perspective
and selling that to make to gain
personal wealth for himself
before he dropped an album and he's
still making money yeah and i honestly
think that's probably low
i would assume that all right
all right all right all right all right
all right forbes
over under forbes has listed kanye west
uh current net worth
at 1.8 billion
that's way under that's a low ball
i don't even think that's close yeah
right
i mean how is forbes there's off all the
time
i mean it's tough because they don't
know right they just what do you mean
they're taking estimates based on
the equity that he would have in company
yeah so this is a good this is a good
example of uh how hard this stuff is to
gauge for some people right some people
it's easy if all their money's tied up
in a public equity you can see how much
they own and all this stuff and you know
whatever he owns a house here and all
this stuff it's it's much easier to
estimate but for someone like kanye who
has so many different sources of income
and owns all these different businesses
it's much harder but
to for context here forbes has it at a
billion just over a billion dollars uh
business insider released a report i
don't know who their source is here but
they had them listed at 6.6 billion
right so six times what forbes had at
the same time period so it's i just
decided that number one six yeah
but that's my point it's it's these
numbers are just an estimate right you
really have no idea but i think it's
comfortable that he's above a billion do
you want to know why i think he's way
above the 1.8 billion why you have his
music sales which they can back into you
have concert tickets you have
merchandise sales they kind of they can
you know have good estimates of that
stuff
everyone knows yeezy is incredibly
valuable so they're trying to estimate
that
what most people
are not good at estimating on the net
worth side
what are the assets he owns
right the homes the science all the
stuff yeah okay so that's one
two is don't forget that he's got a
creative company that he's the founder
and ceo of called donda
that they almost never talk about
so there's yeezy
but then he's got donda as well
how much is that company worth yeah
nobody ever talks about that kanye west
just shows up and says yo i got a
creative company if you can buy my
company and you get all my creative
ideas that's worth a billion dollars
just by that well so i just googled this
real quick and it says enter this is an
already an article from axios
entertainer kanye west sneaker company
easy which was valued at three billion
dollars was valued at three billion
dollars according to a bank of america
document from 2019 reviewed by bloomberg
he was 100 of easy right so when you
think about and there's some kind of
royalty structures and licensing deals
he's worked out with a bunch of
different companies but if it's worth
three billion dollars and he owns a
hundred percent his network is above a
billion
of course
kanye west is a billionaire he's a
marketing genius he's a creative genius
he's also a musical genius but
he may not be the goat musician which is
fine that's okay i don't think that
kanye west considers himself a musician
i think he considers himself a creative
a creator he crea he thinks of himself
as somebody who uh
builds things who constantly is pushing
the
pace of innovation in an industry
musician is just one form of that
creativity right i think that's why he's
so inspiring hey guys bang bang thanks
so much for watching the best business
show today and don't forget to check out
our partner sofi they make all this
possible they're a super app that lets
you save spend borrow earn and invest
all from one single platform and if you
go there today and you sign up for a
sofi invest account you can get between
five dollars and a thousand bucks for
free from sofa not everyone's obviously
gonna get a thousand dollars but
everyone gets something don't say that i
never did anything for you go check them
out at sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofa.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help
[Music]